economía en directo américa de france 24
nuevamente ya la tercera es la vencida
la tercera la bella se va a veces que
hacer un rato daniela pero antes vamos a
hablar de la economía de eeuu porque
técnicamente si entró en recesión unos
dicen que entró otros dicen que no entró
al final vamos a ver a quien le creen
pero no está bien pero no está bien eso
es lo cierto raúl porque el producto
interno bruto se contrajo un 0,2 por
ciento en el segundo trimestre del año y
de esta manera encadena dos trimestres
de caídas consecutivas
tradicionalmente se considera que una
economía ha entrado en recesión cuando
encadena dos trimestres seguidos de
caída del pib como está ocurriendo en
este momento porque el primer trimestre
del año la economía de eeuu se contrajo
en 1,6 por ciento sin embargo ese es un
diagnóstico que no comparte el gobierno
estadounidense porque no es oficial esto
es apenas un concepto informal que han
venido manejando a lo largo de todos
estos años estas décadas los economistas
el día anterior justamente como lo
mencionábamos antes la reserva federal
había dicho que no hay recesión porque
uno de los componentes más importantes
es el empleo que si se está manteniendo
saludable ahora lo que sí se está
descontrolando es la inflación que llevó
justamente a la fed a hacer otro aumento
drástico en las tasas de interés
concretamente 0.75 puntos porcentuales y
ahora pues vamos a ver una evolución en
las tasas en la recesión económica de
2008 llegaron a tocar un 5 25 por ciento
de ahí en adelante del 2009 en adelante
se mantuvieron bajas ahora vuelven a
niveles del 25 % bueno y también una
vería como pues eso pasa en eeuu había
lo mejor no pero sí como nos afecta
estudiando lo primero raúl que quiere
decir es que la reserva federal es un
referente para el resto de bancos del
mundo y casi que la mayoría de bancos
del mundo hacen lo que hace la reserva
federal juan carlos martínez lázaro
profesor de entorno económico de
international university de españa nos
explicó más temprano específicamente
cuáles son esas implicaciones que tiene
esto para américa latina
bueno la verdad es que es difícil de
pronosticar que puede pasar porque va a
depender mucho de cuánto hasta cuánto
suba los tipos de interés la reserva
general y sobre todo cuánto tiempo dure
la inflación pero es verdad que los
efectos en latinoamérica ya se notan
menor crecimiento en eeuu significa
menor crecimiento de latinoamérica dólar
más fuerte significa que si bien las
exportaciones hacia eeuu pueden aumentar
pero porque eso implica unas monedas
locales más más depreciadas frente al
dólar pero también implica que las
importaciones son más caras y por tanto
hay más inflación y como decía antes los
bancos centrales van a tener que estar
haciendo subiendo los tipos de interés
de forma importante y eso significa pues
que el crédito es más caro y eso
significa que tanto consumidores como
empresas pues van a tener mayores costes
a la hora de financiarse y eso me temo
que al final del día significa menor
crecimiento económico por tanto todo
esto está ocurriendo no es una buena
noticia para latinoamérica bajo ningún
bajo ningún concepto y lo deseable sería
que la inflación empezase a aflojar y
por tanto la reserva federal no tuviera
que seguir con este calendario de
subidas de tipos de interés danny y la
motivación de la reserva federal es la
alta inflación le pregunté entonces cómo
se han comportado los precios en este
país puedes regular inflación alta no
solamente es un fenómeno que se atribuye
a la guerra en ucrania se agudizó desde
que inició la guerra en febrero de este
año pero ya veníamos con una alta
inflación desde antes cuando estaban
terminando el 2021 que comenzó a ver
esta crisis de contenedores y eso hace
pues que los precios suban a medida que
hay menos oferta de productos ahora
veamos cómo ha sido la evolución de la
inflación en eeuu pues el objetivo de la
reserva federal y de casi todos los
bancos del mundo es mantener la
inflación ni muy alta ni muy baja un
rango que es considerado propicio es
entre el 2 y el 3 o el 4 por ciento pero
en eeuu como vemos se ha venido
disparando venía dentro de este rango
2021 comienza a subir ahora está en un
9,1 por ciento en un nivel que no se
veía hace al menos 40 años cuatro
décadas y es un fenómeno que si usted
toma y graficó lo puede calcar casi en
muchos países de la región con pocas
excepciones por ejemplo bolivia que ya
hablábamos del tema a lo largo de esta
semana en uno de nuestros programas
hablando de nuestra región danny
cambiamos de tema porque en paraguay los
transportadores están en paro claro los
camioneros y transportadores en general
protestan por lo mismo que han venido
protestando sus colegas en muchos países
de la región y son los altos precios de
los combustibles como ya ha ocurrido en
otros países y lo veníamos diciendo el
presidente abdo benítez anunció un
descenso en el precio de la gasolina y
agregó que también habrá rebajas en los
precios de casi 100 productos de la
canasta básica familiar la estatal
petróleos paraguayos rebajará entonces
en zinc 500 guaraníes que corresponden a
0 073 dólares el litro de dice el tipo 3
y también de la gasolina de 93 octanos
que son dos referencias muy utilizadas
en términos porcentuales esta rebaja
raúl es de casi un 6% pero los
transportistas creen que es insuficiente
cómo están los indicadores económicos
con todo este mundo económico
claro y eeuu moviéndose mucho esta
semana pues las bolsas del mundo
incluida wall street abrieron mayormente
al alza y operan al alza aunque con
variaciones muy leves después de un
miércoles de celebración en el que el
índice tecnológico nasdaq se disparó en
más de un 4% su mayor ganancia diaria en
dos años hoy va subiendo un poco menos
del 1 por ciento y le tengo también una
noticia bursátil y es que jetblue
comprará a spirit airlines por 3 mil 800
millones de dólares para crear así la
quinta aerolínea más grande de eeuu
cifra el día está un 4% interanual que
cayó la economía rusa en el segundo
trimestre de 2022 esto según el
ministerio de finanzas de ese país que a
su vez recordó que en el primer
trimestre el producto interno bruto
había crecido un 35 por ciento o sea
ellos sino están en recesión como si
ésta supuestamente eeuu y pues por
supuesto daniela esta guerra y las
sanciones económicas de occidente de
rusia evidentemente iban a tener un
pacto pues lo estamos viendo ahí con
este 4%
y de contracción en economía de rusia
esto solamente rusia hay que ver ucrania
también como al evadir este año hay
proyecciones bastante pesimistas sobre
cómo les va a ir en el resto del año
porque porque en el primer trimestre
digamos que todavía no teníamos un
efecto seguro de la guerra porque apenas
sucedió un mes de los tres meses que se
están midiendo lo realmente importante
ahora desde el segundo trimestre en
adelante cómo se va a comportar la
economía y saber además cuándo vamos a
conocer estas cifras económicas de
ucrania porque pues como es evidente la
prioridad está en defenderse de esta
invasión y pues bueno ya llegará el
momento entonces de conocer estos datos
económicos que pues serán seguramente
lamentables catastróficos para la
economía de ucrania sobre todo además
con todo esto lo que a uno de los granos
que ya está ahí tratando de exportar se
los granos pero pues hasta ahora pues
todavía está un poco trancada la cosa no
claro y también hay que mirar qué pasa
con los precios del petróleo raúl porque
muchos se preguntan por ejemplo en
colombia porque si colombia produce
petróleo la gasolina está tan alta y es
porque las empresas tienen que vender el
petróleo algo que se las compren y
control es una compañía estatal
de mixta que tienen también accionistas
privados y esos accionistas van a querer
vender el petróleo a lo que mejor se los
ofrezcan así que para ecopetrol tampoco
va a ser fácil
producir un barril un litro de gasolina
más barato de lo que sólo pueden estar
comprando en el mercado internacional es
todo un manejo raúl este mundo
globalizado lo que pasa en china donde
sea pues evidentemente siempre va a
tener repercusión en cualquier lugar del
mundo danny como siempre muchísimas
gracias por toda la información
económica bastante nutrida el día de hoy
mañana con más economía pues vamos a
hablar de deporte